citizens of the reject Nation it is time to
leave our reality and go to another reality
with Batman Gotham by Gaslight you excited John I
am so excited I've heard I've Just Seen The Vibes
of this and I feel like it'd be right up my Alle
I'm uh I've never seen it I know the comic and the
comic is old enough that I don't know how much
they'll follow this little elor thing it's Mike
mola if I remember correctly but I'm very excited
for an elor you lovelies know the drill let us
know in the comments what you want us to watch
next do you want us to go back to the tomorrow
verse do you want us to watch more elor do you
want us to go watch Young Justice what do you want
let us know that's why I pluged it know that we've
been reading it because I see that a lot so let
us know in the comments below what you want next
uh if by now you've noticed we started a certain
other animated show click on over to there as well
because I want you people to know we're watching
the current stuff as well so reject Nation dive
on in hit that notification Bell hit that like
button hit that comment hit all the YouTube things
and as ever thank you to the fine folks at prepper
who make this all very possible they prep we
deliver and then they deliver and it's all
prep thanks to prepper thank you if you want to
watch any of these in their entirety including the
entirety of the my adventures with Superman full
length watch alongs head on over to patreon where
you can watch it beginning to end and enjoy the
Artistry the Majesty the ustc of our resting face
so over there at patreon and become
a super sexy reject without further
Ado let's dive into the Gaslamp district
it's Comic-Con baby Gotham by gasl let's
go now will we get a horse and buggy in the
opening shop is I bet all of my tuppin on
that or whatever the TPP we're going to be still
in America right if that's a word Oh I thought I
got I saw a little oh there is a horse and buy
there is perfect very proud of that silly thing
that just happened may change but things stay the
same in a train we're getting all the modes of
Transport guys what are the chances like this is
literally do they do this on purpose cuz that is
they do they know they know they have booster
Golds time machine they've watched these and
they're like those guys love yeah just for John
Andy the Gotham gay girls presents iy the plant
lady the gayy girls the plant [Music] lady kids
this movie is rated R we don't know what might
happen to those leaves ask your parents about
burlesque and V various other live art forms
we just don't know if fall is coming will Autumn
cause these leaves to fall it's r at R we'll see
let's see those leaves this man is demanding all
them it's not what burles is about by the way it's
not it's true is that one in that East Hollywood
that perlesque bar it's awesome jumbo jumbo clown
shout out to Jumbo's Clown Room beautiful place
now which DC character would hang out there Lobo
Lobo yep and I'm sure the Joker rolls through once
in a while just because he's obligated oh actually
I wonder if he's the villain of this detective
Jack the Ripper we never discovered him that'd
be cool oh my God Jack Napier hey oh wait it
might you gave me a start I thought for a minute
be lonely I hate to see a man lonely uh-oh I got a
generous nature and I'm sure you're generous too a
you mister going all in on this dialogue or maybe
you don't want to wait right here in the alleyway
baby no you took the shortcut through outside
his territory got to pay the Tariff ain't that
right Dicky names Jason remember they're all
Robins it's getting awful late don't go yell
on me boy you know what you get everyone is
Ray Winstone but is it Ray Winstone nope I've
been down the RO too many times Coy we've
been misled before never Ray Winstone now
pay up the first Tim Drake really in elor
I think we might have broke him boys the
B ain't just a story young one oh I like the
cloak holy [__] boys really I wouldn't work
for that guy anymore no no real poor judge
of [Music] action Vengeance now you're in
big Bill dust territory interfering with
my amiable [__] Robins you're bad for
business bad all round iconic villain
build dust yeah got old Billy dust love
him oh oh dude this is our family now
making something here taking something
back from Gotham make something else we got
no choice you'll just chase us down find us
again oh go to St kadala ask for sister
Leslie she'll help you she'll hook it up
would be nice to actually get a Tim Drake
right like we did briefly I guess oh oh
no what a shot so has Ivy withered
they just merked Ivy right off the bat
Stakes I wonder if we'll get Harley because
the Harley Quinn definitely
fits the setting sure oh my
God are there supposed to be from Hell Vibes
oh there definitely are okay definitely Alan
Moore influence is here and tears that's
what turned this dream into a magnificent
reality that and Bruce Wayne's money Capital
Money Money Money this special preview of the
Gotham World's Fair sweet meet me in Old Gotham
Gotham how much money does Bruce have yeah this
day built a town I refer you to medical expert
and Gotham's premier alienist Dr Hugo Strange
yes ride the wheel and I give you my guarantee
as a physician and surgeon you will live how'd
you make that sound so creepy women are being
gutted in the streets like wild game and the
Gotham police stand twiddling their thumbs some
Gin soaked women of the street have met their
fate as is common to their kind as they deserve
wow bro those mut chops women alike will be safe
from Jack Jack the Ripper yes that's what he
calls himself in the letter he sent the Gotham
Gazette sister Leslie that Letter's likely just
another hoax Oh Sister Leslie I heard about this
little city council meeting and thought it was
a good opportunity to see how my money was being
spent and all I see is sour faces I like the
mutton chop idea on his face yeah I've seen
the bodies Bruce cut to pieces like an autopsy
strange the top man at Arkham tells us he's never
seen this kind of controlled savagery before
what about Jonathan Crane That Could also be
a jack ooh that's true latest victim was one of
our orphanage girls Pamela what Pam if I didn't
have sister Leslie when my parents funding the
orphanage is the least I could do your parents
what pearls where are they your evening attire
has already been laid out sir God Alfred in that
hat Immaculate or redhead James Gordon you've
got a dirty mind you do my money's on blonde
mother Leslie is she based on somebody
I can't think of a Leslie but I'm sure
the the comments will let me know when
I'm wrong but nothing's coming to mind
the elor stuff throws me just enough that
I sometimes miss the obvious that's good
yeah it's nice I could just watch but then
they Ru the day that I didn't catch a thing
it's your job it's your one job it's your
only worth in this [Music] life as much as
we're joking like I love the aura of all this
yeah it's so pretty I just love spending time
here and Batman just suits this level
of Gothic yeah now make the Elmer fud
movie there's a Batman versus
Elmer fud it's delightful I need
it this ominous slow walk MH i' be too
controlled for Joker my peace care CR
either that or it's somebody like we
wouldn't think of oh oh an abatar oh
sheeps cat like reflexes I was going to
say you can't kill Selena they did kill
poison I in the opening that's true no I was
characters are are you know highly [Music]
Expendable [Music]
o
sweet oh
yes good sound design yeah
fights ooh it
is yeah you just got
porked oh the old meat door trapo solution he's
more skilled than I would have thought I don't
need or want your help and before you gallantly
offer to escort me home let me assure you I am
quite capable of yeah one of the best uses of
the disappearing that was so good this Ripper
is far worse than the lunatic you're searching for
he's a skilled Hunter you ought to have breakfast
with Hugo Strange up at Arkham Asylum you can
compare useless theories I prefer I ran into
your Ripper earlier this evening approximately
6' 3 in 250 lb left-handed rashal ghou it's very
cabal I mean goes with some of the conspiracy
theories every woman in Gotham is in danger
commissioner a letter from Jack to the Gotham
Gazette we've convinced them to refrain from
publishing it hide your kids hide your wife
this Uninvited visit to my home will not be
repeated this house is my refuge set apart
from all the corruption of go twice in a row
man both great [Music] excellent the Monarch
Theater was where his parents died [Music]
oh John's other job go go auditioning I'm
available for chus line he's ready he can
can can too wield a mad umbrella I'm in
love well that's great news Harvey I'm
sure you're wife will be glad to hear it
this is the 19th century don't be such a
dinosaur polyam is all the rage now Bruce
kids are doing it make yourselves at home
gentlemen I certainly hope not just come
out here naked in front of the both of
us the shade of purple to mirror her 90s outfit
from the Jeff lobe run of long Halloween this is
my club we can catch a handsome here I'd invite
you in for a drink drink but men only at least
we still have something as it should be yes a
handsome what's that expression I've never heard
that once we should Lear new catch a handsome
you know we're going to a men's club you're a
fascinating subject and what have you learned you
were raised in a small Regional circus probably
in a family of performers at some traumatic
event connected to the scar in your left arm
that you try to conceal LED you to the continent
where you reinvented yourself as a nightclub
performer nothing else sister Leslie Tomkins one
of the few people who knew me as a boy she was
the one who told me you were kind she took me
in too she takes in all the helpless protects
them oh I've been a fool Bruce what fetch me a
handsome quickly why did you say those ideas why
did you say those series of sentences fetch me
a handsome quick I now know less what it means
I know just like a handsome spirit tool is it a is
it a a Corvette of some kind me a handsome got to
Google it Marlene what are you doing here a warm
cut is waiting for you and you're out here in the
cold H you've been at the bottle nah it's Batman
this guy's the old woman again is it marleene
Quinn Marlene quinzel what do you know I feel
like it is a Marlene quinzel so this is it then I
won't beg and I won't go hysterical I won't give
you the satisfaction know this I forgive you o
wow no I thought he was going to stop her stop him
seriously
Bruce wow
nice oh I like that it's an attic instead of
caves see up the B the B it's a membership
pin from the Dian Isis Club it was at the
scene the Batman will return it to Gordon
after my analysis and this does however
narrow the field considerably including the
mayor Harvey even Hugo Strange virtually
every wealthy man in Gotham testing your
fingerprints Theory again there are't prints
just a few fibers in the Fastener if I could
match these it will have to wait I've laid
out your morning clothes I have my own manner
of mourning oh she wouldn't want you to
be alone right now it's how I work best
Alfred is that like a bowl full of nugs on his
what is that right there how do you think he
funds all this yeah your original drug dealer
that's right of the Resurrection to eternal
life through our Lord Jesus Christ it was you may
be like unto his glorious body amen or maybe it's
like a group of people is it Hugo Strange cuz
we haven't seen him like a Hugo Strange thing
I don't know they keep so obviously evil yeah
well and Harvey was tired and now bulock was
tired like I feel like they're making a
point out of people who being tired which
is a weird Theory this Ripper is very tired
out last night killing Mr Wayne handwriting
is just laziness oh I read your monograph on
the habits of clinically degenerate lunatics
you believe their cure lies in surgery
oh you knew sister Leslie no I came for
professional reasons to hotamy it's all the
AG he is here you know who he is pardon me
Mr Wayne the commissioner was wondering if you'll
be coming to the memorial yes Chief I'll be right
there I'm sure you could find a way to
tell the Batman to to come to my office
tonight midnight strange I don't know
who strange too clever for your own good
man
gotta we don't take kindly to IMM Merchants you
think that's so sister Leslie want you to askit
her own funeral but I'm hungry Jason he is not
worth the trouble get him loose huh are they just
they they're all the Robins yeah Jason TI tick I
occasionally have odd jobs that need doing oh call
upon me here you'll not go away hungry instead of
the Red Hood he's the redhaired yeah follow me Mr
Bruce Wayne I recognized you sneaking around the
churchyard uhoh if you think you can do me like
you did sister Lesley you're dead wrong fella F
me in Skinner's head everybody knows me oh must
your head damn that went well walls are closing
in yes whoa who's got this special head cage yeah
someone messed up man Arkham's rough wow you go
strange with people in a pit a fual even a bit
early Batman these masks the ones you choose
to wear they show the true self like in that
Twilight Zone episode of course you understand
why I couldn't say more at we saw those wrists
we both know you cannot do your work on me I'm
not a street walker it's antithetical to your
neosis you
can't dang dude this is a tough one
for Batman yeah P getting killed
around [Music] him I want to study this
suit too did he throw him in the pit he
let other people kill him is he going to
use him as some kind of example oh god wow
wow no like do any of them look like
anybody that mask I wonder if they're
going to do some kind of like cord
ofy thing with the dianis club oh
interesting I don't know I mean he
just got the mask but at the same time
I wonder if there are multiple Jacks
[Music] oh who Batman
moment
W waa
steampunk
cool he nice
chemistry oh yep Police Headquarters
the Batman has murdered doctor strange
and escaped in the police Airship oh different
one yes whoa whoa
dang very good at the
knife yeah I'm like what other villains fight
with blades I'm thinking Raj with the he's
got a a scabber blade a lot nice yeah of the
Silhouettes cloak in a cape wow this would be
very cool in live action [Music] yeah yes fisty
cuffs on a blimp blimps to cuffs oh oh boy oh boy
God right into the blades Indiana
Jones them someone's going to get
it Indiana Jones in him
yeah jeez
dude
dang what are you leaping to boy
we got him down to the Nubs whoa
crash like a lead Zeppelin oh nice wow ouch ow on
fire Dam Batman him there he
is oh [Music] no oh
nope he's definitely such just a guy in this yeah
and what about the too many just killed at Arkham
we don't know what happened for certain Bulldog
we catch him and if he's guilty he hangs but I
want him alive je just want to study this suit it
looks like he's got like a double breasted like
bomber jacket yeah he's got like a cloak and then
something underneath and then the pouches are huge
get in there you go do your downtown escapades
usually end with excessive bleeding the belt
and gloves must go immediately any of the bat
autal hold I say open up open up in the name
of the lord they're making it they're doing
it yeah oh is there a problem officer no Mr
Wayne we've just been you should head home
dangerous characters on the streets tonight
anything else gentlemen you must commit
completely to the role let's finish the
scene repetition you must practice yes practice
practice yes yes yes the Bad and the cat ah this
even got my lowkey romance great The Cat In The
Gaslight loving it the boys just found her show
me ah Marley Quinn I saw the circus in the
acrobatic Dismount you used in your show and
then of course in your fighting style in the whip
lion tamer just like he's saying about I grew up
with those cats they don't have anyone else
to protect them until the Batman does he have
a story oh you better believe it oh your parents
are you making them pay the criminals they could
never pay enough could they a no cute Bruce Wayne
you are under arrest for the murder of one Marlene
Mahoney who think hard Wayne maybe you'll remember
I'll contact Harvey he'll clear this all up he's
the one who suggested we look for Mr Wayne in your
hotel excellent you can't imagine I'm actually the
Ripper o get him out of my sight jeez as the
nature of these crimes is so detestable and
Mr Wayne has ample Financial Resources to escape
justice justice BFF will remove the prisoner to
Blackgate Prison at two Harvey you really are
a two-faced man yeah you're just chumming we
we we went got a handsome together you know what
he is duplicitous oh he truly man of Duality he
is dichotomy all of it he just wanted to know
what a handsome was too was the problem nobody
told please enjoy your stay at the hotel Blackgate
yeah we're looking forward to seeing you check out
in a body B prison jokes you think one of your
friends is framing you one of my mentors says
that when you eliminate the impossible whatever
remains however improbable must be the truth
o unfortunately my nocturnal habits ude me from
providing an adequate account of my whereabouts
well you'll just have to explain to Gordon that
you're the Batman Batman has an ironclad Alibi
for the first murder Batman's Effectiveness
depends upon every moment you're in here puts
women in danger if you won't tell Gordon then I
will yes step up bro I'll be damned if I'll let
another girl be murdered so you can keep your
precious secret but I think ultimately you'll
find this was all for the best love everyone's
motivation yeah that's a solid ultimatum bring
this to my townhouse on Bell Avenue and my man
there will give you $100 get it there within 30
minutes he'll give you $200 get it there and
10 I'll give you half a clown I need a free
pizza
excellent who is next who will face Cyrus Gold oh
Cyrus gold no weaklings I'll be
you in private no time like the
present yeah [Music]
buddy
nice nice great touch with the stick why you
sitting on your asses it's a damn D Brook
there Irish Batman oh that's so good blury man I
hope that was Bruce Greenwood just doing his best
bro that was fantastic I was gon to say where
where what uh you know lineage does the Wayne
Sur name come from it's got to be some Irish I
need to see Commissioner Gordon immediately you
never slow down do you I can't imagine what I
ever saw an like you sounds awful awful rippery
someone is liable to get hurt and sooner or
later you will real rippery he's down at the
fairgrounds making sure everything ship shap the
fairgrounds hurry the Riddler's going to flood
the fair inel Ripper the Ridler yep that's who it
is yep if you bet on every horse you're going to
win something one one of those it's gonna be no
one it's going to be Jack the Ripper yeah I still
say we take the wagon the horse and whatever this
is and SK ble we're going to do the job Jason now
shut your bone box and push it's them three in a
trench coat their Jack yeah solved it Coy in your
face good job now go yes what do
we got what's the tech [Music]
yeah I love this too this feels like very
appropriately vatman but perfectly out of
History where Fair blending those worlds
together yeah yeah Ace hey I thought I was
all alone embarrassing as it sounds you gave me
quite a start a I like them two working together
Selena oh false wall don't don't tell me is
it Gordon it can't be Gordon I need to talk to
your husband is he home he's a good man what the
best man in this horrible City what did a woman
come here looking for him walk in here off the
streets I should hope not no uh-uh I don't believe
this no oh this this could just be his ch ear day
wall oh look at them gloves oh no no no we liked
him so much damn damn I never would have predicted
it no they totally got me that's not bad actually
we named everyone else that's not bad I I should
have called the second Harvey started to be
real suspicious there at the end I was like
yeah kid mislead he needs to be severe no he's
gentle as a lamb with us he simply burns the
sin out of us whoa that is nutty I suppose it's
a dreadful betrayal of confidence but I simply
see no other way it's in your very nature to play
false with your illicit lover uh damn oh [Music]
no yes that's a cosplay waiting
to happen yeah no a 7% solution
of Lum 3% heroin and alcohol woo but it
is hardly a cure forry only I only Jack
has the remedy for that vile ill wow damn
Nation you'll pay for that oh was that
a word at this time Jim just invented it
he did he's a sophisticated guy Jim Jack
Gordon tag the no okay fine dra
cat oh back bike Sweet It's like
got Tomahawk that thing is awesome
yeah it's like made out of a piece
of a train engine or something the
oversweet fragrance you use to cover
your putrifying stench nearly burns my
eyes oh we have a b sign amazing oh that's so
good niceoo I love it yes very good touch oh
my God and it's fighting James and oh so good
and perfect like smudgy like yeah no nice try
what does a light in the darkness do it draws
flies vile like you can't have no light man I
promise the people of Gotham to clean the scum
thieves murderers confidence Men immigrants
illiterates anarchists it's a big old list
not a great guy your corruption and Decay
will spill down over this Carnival as a warning
to all your kind am man is a real incel here
dark yes sir get him Batman left-handed
oh the nuns beat that wickedness out of
me use my right except for Jack's work dang
that's a cool twist too my sister was ruler
slapped by a nun for right and Lefty really
yep damn have you any other injuries no I'm
Bruce jeez dude oh they do really make him
feel like a prize fighter or an ex fighter
oh I'm a trained fighter London
prize ring rules there were no
rules at antium though were there James
there are no rules in hell yeah that's a
bar o
it's a cool set piece too with the gas light
becoming part of the yeah destruction set
piece come on Selena ah Into The
Inferno man what a set piece
yeah uhoh don't save him I know you got to
me oh God but he's going to pull you over oh
no oh nah man you're stuck in here with me sweet
choice whoa I saw your work on your wife they're
the worst problems of all sell themselves
too cheap what an impossible to please Ian
guy who this is where we belong no it's where you
belong I paid Houdini $300 for that trick yes
you did amazing Houdini canonical unofficial
sidekick you know helping out y razell
ghoul in this universe Houdini that's
going to be my Batman comic is the Adventures
of Batman Houdini oh wow is he what a shot
whoa
no cleansing fire wow damn it's
couldn't happen to a nicer guy
yep what a trustful yeah it's good thing
that steel was soft never mind until it
wasn't let's go bat and the
cat whoa just feel the heat
yeah you should have run when you had the chance
well I was fairly doped up my man and the robins
yes where there smoke there's fire and there
you'll always be sir Alfred always clutch no
wonder Alfred's a constant he's always a great
character no matter how big how small and I love
that the robins are in this yeah Belong To You
Alfred good Lord no sir they belong to you sweet
pick up Sister Leslie's work take on some Wards in
a time we're having Wards actually might be less
problematic oh God and the hope of Gotham withed
it was all phony anyway oh we'll make something
new something better that's right I like these
kids we'll keep them little bat family starting
out cool nicely done yep Bruce Greenwood and
Jennifer Carpenter Chris CIO a lot of voice
actors oh Tera strong was Marley that's why I
was like Harley yeah I was like it's at least
got to be a vocal tribute of some kind dang
man that was intense that was very cool that
was intense yeah man absolutely I mean obviously
like the aesthetic choice to yeah set it in this
what is that the 19 the 1800s the 19th century
19th century yeah no I just love the atmosphere
and I I really enjoyed the air that they cuz I I
I saw the run time I was like oh an hour and 17
minutes that's on the shorter side but uh yeah I
thought this managed to like breathe very nicely
while also feeling like I don't know it had that
like dark but fun aura that like an elor's Tale To
Me often does and it didn't like hold on too long
to anything because it was an elor so the stakes
were the right amount of high like you you got to
breathe it in have the fun novelty of Who's Who
and then like it dove into the story and it didn't
overstay its welcome in the else World which I
liked yeah and it plays off of the associ or you
go strange you're like oh he's got to be up he's
just another kind of around involved but not truly
really significantly responsible or anything like
that and and the implication he did know who Bruce
Wayne was was fun because that's one of the things
you go strange does in the comics uh like the the
playing our expectation of who it's going to be
against like I really thought it was going to be
rash hugle like I because I was like the way he
fought the way like all those things was really
fun as a comic fan to have the S World Absol
absolutely yeah yeah even the mutton shops rashal
go looks like he fits the 19th century totally I
mean that's the thing is I see something like this
and I'm like man I would watch I would watch a
series set in this universe you know I would watch
those takes on like so many the potential for so
many fun takes and adaptations of characters just
you know clearly presents itself through something
like this and I really like the ones that we got
like I really liked the little IV inclusion uh
you know Selena Kyle I thought was really nicely
handled here um but also too I mean for how you
know compact it is in a lot of ways it's not I
like that they also didn't go too far and like
over stuff it with like that's a guy that's single
you're not like yeah so like it it's allowed to
be its own thing while also having you know a lot
of the things that you want from this Pro and the
first Tim Drake sure finally we I mean the robin
allowed for Tim Drake he's a robin too uh but it
allowed for us to discover new things like that
which I thought was exciting and and I don't know
this was like really unique for an elor because
I felt the stakes were high enough that I cared
about everybody but it didn't feel oh it is Mike
MCN NOA hell yeah 1989 that was the comic and he
and he wrote like Hellboy Comics yeah Mike mca's
iconic his art is so specifically him and yeah
Hellboy his big claim to fame as father Callahan
yeah Gordon oh okay fights Gordon into a ferris
wheel where Gordon yeah okay but where's Gordon's
commission uh oh there he is he was credited way
lower got Scott Patterson I saw the Callahan I was
like oh it's father Callahan I don't remember him
um must been a small part John Demario was bulock
uh yui was Harvey which is awesome yeah yeah yeah
uh I love Bruce Tim got a cameos Arkham radio man
he's had a couple I feel like we've seen a couple
of these where he's cameoed his like little bit
parts and stuff like that I like that a lot yeah
um but and two I I mean again oh no no no that
was Barbara Gordon right that was Barbara Gordon
with the the that's that's that's the thing is
is there are enough characters that you're like
okay wait a minute cuz yeah it's like you there's
like does Harvey always come with a Gilda I feel
like that I associate that character so strongly
with the long Halloween that like she's mentioned
here and I'm like I usually think of her as just
a long Halloween charact like I don't think I mean
Harvey D pops in and out but he's been toofaced
for so long I don't think back to the Harvey days
uh also I love that Anthony had was Alfred because
he's so good on Ted lasso is that who that was Ted
lasso zone of course yes for owner dude Giles
freaking him I forget his name yeah what's his
name uh what is his name he's the former owner
of the football club the enemy the antagonist
he's uh uh uh there he is Hannah watting Ham's
douchy ex-husband yes we need TV there we go
TV TV what's his name what's his name oh yeah
Ted rert there you go yeah that evil bugger and
the Repo Man if any Genetic Opera heads are out
there um he was so good as Alfred uh yeah and I
like I love never would have thought of that but
I love that choice and even if we never got to
see it live action I'm like a cool I'm glad he's
in the pantheon he played frankenfurter on the
Picadilly stage for Rocky Horror oh that's excit
love this man more and more the more credits I
read had doing the work he records albums he's
uh he he does musical stuff too good man but uh
yeah no I thought that was actually a really cool
wrap up to this to have it be Gordon a because I
I wouldn't have expected it Gordon is always a
character and especially through the character
characterization they had here uh I thought that
he was you know very he had all his Gordon flavors
that you want where you feel comforted by his
presence you you like him generally he seems like
a guy with Integrity but I thought the reasoning
they found to make it him as it pertains to this
world uh was well thought out and it would have to
be somebody who again they go back to that thing
of like he's a sophisticated guy who's making
himself look you know like an uneducated guy
and it's a good having the letter in his own
pocket saying that that they going to see it
him dreaming of Barbara Gordon being hurt as a
mislead because he's just having the nightmare
about his own wife being horrible yes absolutely
and like the way that it bounces off of the whole
Batman thing is like you know he's got the Playboy
public persona but he's out here you know in the
nighttime obviously you know enacting justice so
then you have like the reverse the guy who in you
know plain day is upstanding and is enacting that
Justice and at night is you know bringing to life
the most perverse the most sort of crazed and
zealous version of that yeah real aab situation
sure yeah and I mean too it's got that Gruff kind
of nasty like yeah all the coppers feel like they
just bludgeon you at any point and like i' love
that the only one we usually only have one cop we
can trust in Gotham and that's Gordon because
he trusts Batman and in this case it's a very
clever twist because I never saw it coming I
also really like the use of the iconography
of Gordon like I love that they use the bat light
against him instead of he's the one using it like
there were just so many moments that are iconic
Batman moments used really creatively here yeah
no totally like I I I feel like this this was very
gratifying in that way because again it had so
many satisfying things that you would want and so
many things that made me feel like I was in some
ways watching like a classic episode in a good
way not you know sometimes calling something like
an episode is is like a slight but I thought but
yeah this this made me feel like I was watching
the animated series at certain points again and I
love the little Sly asides and you having uh the
three robins paid tribute to having Alfred kind
of bring them on of his own accord and we're on
the Wiki page right now just to get the cast but
I see here it says uh referencing Sherlock Holmes
they made the Baker Street of regulars into Robins
that is so fun hey yeah well and that's the thing
too is yeah you've got Sherlock Holmes in here
you obviously have stuff that hearkens to from
hell and I think having Jack the Ripper is a
really good historical pull for a Batman story
like this it's it's got so much Mystique already
such a larger than life figure you know much has
been much ink has been spilled over the blood
he has spilled I mean alen Mo stuff for Comic
fans like you said that run frame like there's
definitely moments where it even ties into our
mythology in comics yeah totally so like this
and and the way it inhabited that world used the
historical fiction but also used the again Batman
characters to tie it all around I was like damn
if these weren't all you know clearly fictional
characters I'd be like this is kind of a solid
Theory right here yeah like oh you don't I wonder
if there was any theories that the Ripper was a
cop I bet there must be there has to you know
I mean like I feel like there was a foundation
there in something cuz you know it's like yeah
you have that whole thing about like he's got a
a knowledge of like s he like all of his murders
are very surgical yeah and they have at least a
moment here where you see like okay Gordon's at
least been trained in autopsy and they say like
oh these are sort of similar to autopsies in a way
and uh and yeah it's like I have to imagine that
in the real case like I I'm not an expert by any
stretch but I feel like they've they've looked at
surgeons or people with that kind of experience
but they would have had to have looked uh at you
know some kind of law enforcement or coroner
somebody like that I'm also really curious
like what the I just wrote scrolled on C response
people seem to like this quite a bit but I'm very
curious about how something that turns a beloved
character this evil went because like I think it
was very useful but I know a lot of people like
I can't trange something that like no it's like
an else world like that's the fun of it like
Thomas Wayne being Batman changes everything
like the Joker like that's what I like about an
not when it's one little twe when they go Full
Tilt like this I got to be fully surprised yeah
totally and it's like he fought in the War it's
you know's he's traumatized from like the Civil
War yeah uh so like yeah it's it's a great again
it makes sense that if he had been put into that
moment in time these events come together where
they not have if he is yeah of a later period in
time like we're used to seeing him and this very
success F did a thing another of the animated
movies we watched a while ago I think failed at
one of the only villains I didn't like in the Teen
Titans where I was like he's just an angry Zealot
and it didn't feel weighted blood I hated this
guy yeah like all of his zealotry was like gross
like the performance the writing everything felt
like I wanted him to feel like yeah you just feel
like the like the the anger and the like righteous
hatred it's it's yeah it's that he feels righteous
in that awfulness and I didn't feel that from
Brother Blood yeah it's that looking down you're
looking down on everyone as just filthy and and
agents of you know Idle Hands of the devil agents
of you know corrosion and all that stuff and and
everybody he looks upon comes with this sort of
scourge of judgment and uh and yeah like I thought
they captured that psychosis really nicely and two
you know we don't really see him go to Arkham or
whatever but it's like it's in fitting with the
kinds of people would wind up there but also
in a very again historically appropriate way
because you would have had you know the the very
moralistic arguments and the class-based arguments
and stuff like that and which I like how they
addressed and it didn't get heavy-handed but they
were like put at the top and then it stayed part
of the like the fabric yeah and it makes sense
too because there are like you know it comes in
varying degrees because they touch on again the
class angle and the idea that like oh you know
if they were killing men you would have figured
this out a long time ago or at least and then
people counter well you know if it was affluent
women at the very least we would have figured
this out a long time ago it's you know it's uh
the the women on the fringes of society who are
being plagued upon and how people look on that I
feel like that's you know a a Nuance that's very
reasonable I feel like anytime you directly be
like he's targeting women because of this reason
you know it dog whistles certain people to be like
but this makes perfect sense and it also again
lines up with the mo of historical Jack the Ripper
so yeah having I thought having that really strong
Selena perspective as she was a favorite I really
love that her motiv was justified I love that she
would have done exactly what she did at every turn
I loved her origin I thought the cat element was
fun fun fact Greg Griffin is the voice of sister
Leslie Tomkins and Jason Todd and also Selena
Kyle's singing voice what a range of different
roles in one movie that's singing voice and I love
that we got a musical number yeah full on which
told plot elements yeah and a and a and a romantic
subplot again that felt earned felt earned it felt
uh natural and organic and it fueled the plot
it gave him an alibi it also gave him an out
it also gave her a lot to do like that's what
you want a true love story to feel like and
she also was like an Irene uh what's her name
uh Sherlock oh oh oh oh yeah ohler is it Adler
yes it is she got to be like that stand in which
also is a really fun female lead of the time and
dressed like her but also nodded towards Selena
Kyle's Tim sale outfit which is that purple that
might have been a coincidence but it felt like
that tra of purple so a lot of fun yeah and with
the the the Sherlock Holmes I mean then you have
Alfred is kind of like John Watson the true John
Watson not the bumbly guy but yeah the guy who's
looking out for the wellbeing of Sherlock Holmes
and facilitating you know his Brilliance along
the way this was fun man I really dug this yeah
this this was terrific and it makes me curious to
go and read the comic and and see what that take
I'm so glad I haven't read it in so long because
I don't I think the Gordon twist is accurate but
I don't remember yeah but I think that came out
in ' 89 and I think I probably read it in like
'96 like I remember I think I was like a child
that had just discovered Hellboy so I was like oh
so it would not be something I remember at all
but uh that was a blast yeah this was terrific
I really like this a lot and again like
such economical but also fluid breathable
storytelling and yeah like really great use
of everything at this movie's disposal thank
you elor that was so much fun do we have uh
any patrons oh we're gonna save that for the
next Super all right all right we're going to
be saving that so super sexy rejects pay pay
attention stay tuned one of those things pay
tuned to our adventures with and of and about
Superman very excited to dive into more of that
uh and please let us know in the comments what
is your favorite elor let us know if there's any
of the other else worlds you want us to check out
do you want to to go back to tomorrow first
what do you want next hit that notification
Bell hit that like button leave comments below
and we'll be back some more goodness very very
soon and let us know what you thought of
this one because I'm really curious with
this more than most uh how this was received
because obviously we weren't we weren't there
for it so much love reject Nation we'll see
you very soon with another adventure in see
t